bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france pour quelles raisons
majeures à vos yeux faut-il ouvrir les
boîtes de nuit fin juin pour deux
raisons d'abord une raison sanitaire
parce que la fête fait partie de la vie
il vaut mieux considérer qu'elles auront
lieu et que si les fêtes ont lieu il
vaut mieux qu'elle les ait lieu dans des
endroits gérer encadré avec le respect
des normes sanitaires plutôt que de
manière tout à fait sauvage chez les
particuliers ou dans des lieux publics
et d'adapter et la deuxième raison c'est
une raison de sécurité
une raison de sécurité tranquillité
publique parce que l'année dernière en
2001 lorsque les discothèques été fermés
on a vu des fêtes sauvages organisées
sur les plages dans nos stations
balnéaires ou dans des parcs ou en tout
cas dans des lieux publics inadapté il
vaut mieux quand on est mère d'une
station balnéaire avoir des fêtes dans
un exutoire gérés par des professionnels
avec des normes sanitaires plutôt que
d'avoir des fêtes sauvages et des excès
qu'on n'arrive pas à gérer
est ce qu'il serait possible de
sécuriser par exemple les plages ou les
lieux susceptibles d'accueillir des
rassemblements sauvages aux sables
d'olonne il ya vingt-deux kilomètres de
côtes et une douzaine de kilomètres de
plage vous voyez que la police
municipale ou nationale est absolument
incapable d'assurer la surveillance est
d'empêcher les faits de sauvages sur 22
km de littoral
donc on a besoin de lieux de fête
simplement il faut avoir des normes
drastiques draconiennes présenter des
tests restent à distance ouvrir des
espaces à l'extérieur faire confiance
aux responsables et aux professionnels
qui gèrent ces établissements parce que
penser qu'il n'y aura pas de fête et pas
de faits de sauvage c'est illusoire et
donc le gouvernement
si les choses continuent à aller mieux
si la vaccination continue à progresser
dans le pays doit envisager cette
ouverture au mois de juillet prochain
est-ce que vous échangez avec les
autorités comme on dit elle pour
l'instant c'est le seul domaine
d'activité dans lequel en
jean pas une ouverture baissière assez
difficile à comprendre dès lors prendre
a ouvert les cinémas les ventes surface
l'e commerce en général je pense qu'on
peut avoir des jours heureux je veux
avoir des normes sanitaires on peut
avoir
on l'a dit dans le communiqué des
appareils de purification de l'air qui
permettent de réguler le risque de
limiter les risques dans ces lieux de
fête et je pense que ne pas le prévoir
ce n'est pas être très raisonnable et
c'est un moyen d'organiser le bazar en
dehors de ces lieux de fête prévue à cet
effet alors il ya aussi l impact
économique quelle serait l'ampleur des
dégâts dans votre commune notamment
c'est le gouvernement n'autorise pas les
boîtes les discothèques à rouvrir fin
gens comme vous ne réclamez vous savez
les cerveaux de l'âne c'est une station
balnéaire familiale ça n'est pas un
c'est pas bizarre si vous voulez donc le
risque économique est limitée aux sables
d'olonne néanmoins je pense que dans une
station balnéaire comme les sables dont
on a besoin de lieux de fête encadré et
ça ferait vraiment des fois à
l'équilibré général de la vie des
sablais et des touristes cet été si les
discothèques n'étaient pas ouvertes
l'avait alors vous réclamez aussi sur un
autre dossier à davantage de doses
antico vide pour votre station où on est
la campagne de vaccination sables
d'olonne mais si vous voulez on a on a
une campagne de vaccination qui dépend
directement du nombre de doses qui nous
sont fournies par le gouvernement et
aujourd'hui avec les doses qu'on reçoit
on a du mal à vacciner l'ensemble de
notre population locale on est à une
moyenne de vaccination de 900 personnes
par jour à ce rythme là on aurait fini
de vacciner la population des sables
d'olonne et de son agglomération au mois
de septembre prochain
et donc si on veut pouvoir augmenter la
couverture vaccinale dans notre pays est
si on veut pouvoir imaginer vacciner les
touristes de passage il faudrait qu'on
ait beaucoup plus de doses et on peut
paraître faire du jour au lendemain il
faut qu'on se structure vous savez c'est
sur les mairies que pèse la charge de
l'organisation de la vaccination
donc il faut à la fois plus de dos et
nous laisser le temps de
monter en puissance pour voir vacciner
non seulement les locaux mais mais
d'autres personnes qui viendraient en
visite ou passer des vacances chez nous
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne yannick moreau jean rappelle que
vous êtes maire divers-droite des sables
d'olonne